i hope everyone's having a lovely
thursday
and is uh ready for this very last day
in march everyone's ready for april next
hope everyone is doing great
so
just to uh get going as we always do
very first thing
who's hiring
now i know that not everyone can jump in
and say because in fact no one can say
anything on screen
what i'd like everyone to do if you are
hiring go to our slack you know the ny
hacker slack on go to the job postings
channel and put your job up there let us
know who's hiring and anyone who wants a
job go to job postings and get hired
it's a great symbiosis for people who
want to hire people who want to get
hired go and meet
since i am on camera i will take the
opportunity to say that my company
lander analytics is hiring for a few
positions both part-time and full-time
we're very flexible
looking for someone doing technical
sales that someone actually understands
the technology and can do a little bit
of selling and a data science engineer
someone really good of linux but also
good with the ideas behind r and python
mainly some really great linux and
databases
if you want to learn more about either
of those go to landeranalytics.com
careers
we'll post that also in the job postings
channel so it's up there
as always the second thing we always do
is pizza
so today i actually got a vodka slice
with mushrooms on it and you look at the
back has some good charring and the
front has good cheese lock but it has
been sitting on my desk for about five
minutes now so i'm very proud of this
slice
if the vodka slice is really good i'm a
big fan of vodka slices so anyone else
who is having food of us or beverages or
whatever please let us know in the chat
uh let us know where you're eating from
if you're eating pizza if you're eating
some other food if you have a beer if
you have soda if you have ice cream if
you have tea or water let us know what
you're eating and drinking always fun
just to
um
just to have some people no not knowing
where to eat it's always a good time
next up actually i'm going to take a
moment to share a screen very
momentarily i rarely share my screen
during these things but it's something
i'm very very proud of and i want to
show everybody someone just gives me one
second
i will
figure out how i'm supposed to share
just one screen
of course i didn't test this out i just
came up this idea right now
and
how do you share just an application
so you think i've never done this before
okay well i'm going to share one screen
then
all right
and we have the reason i want to share
the screen of you
is because we have a new website
and i am very proud of all the work that
went into this website so i wanted to
make sure everyone had a chance to see
it
um i can't tell my screen is sharing so
bill can you tell me is my screen
sharing
all right great thank you this is our
brand new website if you go to
nyhackr.org
you can see this
you see it's been massively redone
anyone who saw the old website knew it
was not attractive and knew that it was
not very user friendly we have fixed all
of that
here on the home page it lists the up
most recent upcoming meetup which is
happening right now you're at it
it shows hey look there's bill talking
about the meetup see we have it right
here
so the home page has that if there's no
upcoming meetup has some generic
information
there's an about page where you can
learn a little bit about the meetup and
its history and see some of its sponsors
now the big improvement here is past
talks
this actually is so much more useful now
as it highlights the four most recent
talks to show you hey who spoke most
recently and then the search capability
is so much better let's say you just
want to search generically for
ggplot you search up here and it filters
it down to all the talks over the years
that have gigipod
if there's a video
there is a little
play button right here where you see the
video if you want more details
you can come here and click the plus
button and it gives you all the details
about the meetup including where to find
the links let me see if i open that that
should take us right to
the slides too so you have both the
video under the more details and the
video if available right here in the
table you can also search for individual
speakers let's say we want to search for
hadley wickham
you come here and you can see all the
times he spoke at the meetup and if
there's a video available the video is
here and
you can also click the plus sign to get
to the slides and get more information
so we're really excited about this
the events tab will show you upcoming
events in the community right now we
have the
new york r conference which i'll talk
about a little bit and the government
conference coming up in december and
we'll post other events as they occur
then under the more tab we have our
pizza poll which we haven't been able to
collect data for for two years but the
chart actually works now it actually
looks right and is usable and you can
actually zoom in and scroll across it
it's a big big improvement also under
more are books
we have a very large community and a lot
of members of our community have written
books this is a place to come check out
books written by the community and if
you notice every time it loads it loads
in a random order this we could always
see what comes up at the top if you've
written a book and i have not included
you up here let me know and we'll get
your book added up here we like to share
how all this cool stuff everyone's doing
and there is a contact page if you want
to get in touch here's a gateway to
contact us and learn more about meetup
let us know what's going on
there is a button here for slack so you
can get to them more easily if you don't
remember the long url just come to
nyhakr.org and find the slack button and
these are links to
our twitter and our github before the
meetup
so i'm very proud of this and i want to
give a big thank you to joe marlow and
nicole deljudis for building this they
put a lot of effort into this
they made it really really beautiful
those of you saw the old one you know
this is three generations forward for
how amazing it is and by the way it is
written in r
because of course that's how we do
things here so if i can just get a big
virtual applause for joe and nicole for
all their effort they put into doing
this it was really amazing i am really
really excited by everything they did so
thank you everyone for uh making this
such a for them for making it so amazing
again my hack or andyhackguard.org to
check it out
a few more announcements then we'll get
going
um
we are hoping to return to in person
and don't worry there will be in-person
and virtual we will do both
but we need space getting space in new
york city was hard before the pandemic
it's harder now
so if anyone wants to host us for the
meetup to have 100 data scientists come
into your office hopefully in a cove and
safe environment
let us know
we are looking for april hopefully if
there's no if there's another surge and
beyond that so be and touch me go to
that contact page on the newly to
redesign website tweet me email me
comment on my github whatever you want
to do let me know if you have space we
would love to have you hosting us
it's a great group of people
let us know we would really really love
to have someone host us so please
message me uh
our normal hosts aren't open yet and we
won't have a big warp to our host we
want to share the love and be around as
many people as possible so let me know
um one thing i forgot to mention about
the website if you do want to make a
contribution to this newly beautiful
website github.com
to public all the code is publicly
available head up there and we'd be
happy to have you contribute
coming up in june
in person and virtual the new york r
meetup we are very very excited for this
june 8th through 10th it'll be both in
person
hopefully as long as nothing goes wrong
in the world and virtual as well uh we
have workshops in june 8th the workshops
are being led by max kuhn euro yanson's
dean natalie malcolm barrett and lucy
d'agostino mcgowan
and we have a whole lineup of speakers
it's really great we have assamatumi
jennifer hill andrew gellman sarah
contenzaro and wes mckinney and amongst
many other speakers i can only didn't
want to highlight everybody's need to
highlight a few so it's really going to
be awesome
use discount code ny hack r for 20
discount we'd love to have you there
we're also looking for anyone who wants
to sponsor wants to have a booth let us
know contact us we want to be a sponsor
also we're looking for artists a few
years ago we started having an art
auction where people make art either by
hand or generative we would auction it
off and all the money would get donated
to the r foundation the money goes to
good cause and it's a lot of fun and
someone gets your artwork so if you want
to
donate art and have the proceeds go to
the r foundation
be in touch and we'll happily auction
off all of your art
then lastly today
manning books manning publications has
given us a discount code to share with
the group
so if you would like a 35 discount on
any of their products
you can go to manning's website and use
code and this is a lot this code
and we'll put in the chat
mtp
ny
stat 22.
i'm not sure where that chat code came
from but that's what they have and we'll
put a link
mtpnystat22 for 35 off
and for all of you here today we are
going to choose three
four random winners three random winners
three random winners and we're going to
be giving away these following books
good code bad code by tom long
five lines of code by christian claussen
and street coder by siddharth campanoglu
so at the end after bill's talk before
questions yeah before the questions
we're going to give away these three
books to people who are present here
right now
so we're looking forward to giving those
books away looking forward to this great
talk bill is a and he's now a
three-piece member of the three-timers
club
uh he's given a few excellent talks
before and we are really excited for
this so everyone please welcome with a
virtual applause built to the stage
thank you thank you
thank you can you hear me chad i can
hear you
perfect and go full screen
[Music]
there we go perfect okay
so i'm super psyched to be here um this
is a very cool topic in my opinion um we
will be today unpacking tesla's
autonomous driving models um an outside
in view
uh before we start
big thank you to these people um they
helped me
learn to present better revise the
content it's a much better presentation
because of these people so for that
thank you
and this was pretty cool in the
headlines some of you may or may not
have seen this
but as of yesterday waymo
uh began
[Music]
full driverless tax very timely uh very
relevant for this topic
um
just to kind of set the top context a
little bit um before
uh getting into the actual agenda um
tesla does this really cool thing every
18 months or so
they present three four hours
on their thinking their methods their
approach to
autonomous driving the most recent one
was in august of 2021 prior to that was
2019
um they open source their methodologies
to a certain degree and that's really
cool i think um
but if you look at the headlines
they were almost across the board
captured by their announcement of
building a robot
and to me that's the wrong emphasis
because
they're at the frontier of a lot of cool
methodologies and that's what we're
going to talk about today
so
there's really three things um
would like you to take away from from
today's discussion first
is their approach to vision
and the big thing there is vector space
image
single image one label vector composite
image composite labels really cool
we're going to go through the intuition
of that
we're going to go
through what it looks like from a data
perspective
and what it looks like from the network
and the implications are pretty profound
uh two
we'll go through the planning module and
the network architecture
and lastly
we'll talk about the so what of it so
how does this how is this meaningful or
relevant to me
in different industries and we'll just
dabble on a tiny code segment that
captures um
an important part of the method there's
lots of
good resources on the web for for the
deep learning methods there's one in
particular i'd like to highlight
uh
myself i work at bank of montreal
a guest lecturer at columbia i'm a
student at georgia tech
here's how you can reach me
and we're hiring too um
personally on my team uh data scientists
senior data scientists senior data
engineers
many of my colleagues in the anti-money
laundering group
cyber crime
uh ai
uh
it's a cool bank um i've been there for
two and a half years now
it is by and large filled with smart
ambitious
and kind people so to me that's a very
cool combination it has a very
distinctly for a good reason
a canadian feel to it and
in a twist of irony
the bank of montreal is headquartered in
toronto
okay um
disclaimer i'm in no way shape or form
associated with tesla i'm more of a
groupie uh i try to absorb as much
information as they put out and they do
put out a lot
um
it's just kind of cool it's uh
they do a lot of cool stuff i try to
internalize it as much as i can
um
the the two folks here on the screen
um are rock stars in my humble opinion
so
uh i try to learn from them and i try to
think through what they're doing how i
can apply that in my role
so
being an unsocialized
teenager
taking lots of things apart putting them
back together again reading lots of
science fiction
i began to expect that we were going to
have flying cars and jet packs um
this
autonomous driving to me
is in a similar ballpark and that's part
of what motivates me
okay um
the big transition you're going to see
here is from image space to vector space
and multi-headed deep learning models
we'll go into the network there
and what you see here
on
the lower right
this
is the network
architecture
for the vision
the vision components
of tesla's autonomous driving and and
one of the goals for today
is to provide an intuition of what this
is
and to provide a view of the
architecture
that put this together
with the deep learning
um
it's much less about the features the
network figures that out for you and the
thinking goes into
presenting the data and the architecture
so for that reason that'll be the focus
of today's
discussion
so hopefully at the end of this you'll
have a good intuition of what all this
is
and to put this in context in the
broader architecture picture
there's the vision component so what
comes in our pictures what goes out
are objects that are recognized
in time and space the vectors
those feed into a planner
which has a lot to do with optimization
we'll touch on that so those are the two
big parts we're going to touch on today
okay
let's look at that
okay um
what is the intuition of vector space um
for me as i was unpacking this getting a
mental map of what this is and uh shout
out to jd that was a solid tweet
i need that mental
map
to put things together
so that's the journey will go on
together today
that mental map should drive us to an
intuition
a tesla has in it eight cameras uh one
rear facing two here by the doors two
here by the fenders and three forward
facing cameras this way eight
um eight images and that's going to be
the entry point to our network so
so here's a visual
of
what those eight cameras see
they come into a neural network
and the vector space is visualized here
on the console
so so here the red lines are the curves
the white lines
are the the lines on the road and and
it's the network that's painting those
vectors so images in
vectors out
so let's get a little deeper into the
network
so a few years back
tesla was operating in the image space
what does that really mean practically
so
each camera
feeds its own segment its own backbone
of an object detection network
each one of those
detections the the predictions of what
those objects are individually
come out and are fused together
come into the planning model
and the planning model is going to
output
stay in your lane keep your distance
from the car in front of you it's kind
of the scope was highway only forward
only
but the key here is
scalar images in
scalar detections
eight cameras eight detections
fuse
and and act in vector space
so what changes with vector space
here we go
so in vector space and we're going to
talk a lot about this but but the the
essence of it
is take your eight images and land them
in one raster
so
eight cameras
one composite raster
one vector of labels
and that's what we're going to feed into
the object detection
then we model and you know in the years
since the previous version uh the
as they
aspire towards the full self-driving uh
the sophistication of the model is more
is much greater so so now what outputs
is the plan a driving plan for the next
10 to 15 seconds or so
that
that estimates position velocity
acceleration
pretty cool
so here's a visual of what predictions
look like in image space and everything
we see here on this every prediction we
see here
is
based on a prediction from a single
image and there's a lot of predictions
going on here we could see
the lines in the road the curbs
the the stop signs the cars in front
um
pretty cool stuff
but there's two big challenges here
um
okay
so
what we're seeing here
is
each individual image predicting the
curves as the car is getting summoned um
and image by image the predictions are
pretty good these curves those are
pretty good estimates
but where it starts to fall apart is in
the fusion
of those predictions into vector space
so
this on the bottom
is a visual of what that fusion is doing
and you can see it has a jagged quality
it has
it's very discontinuous at places
and it's a very very challenging vector
space to drive it
challenge number two
um
object detections where the object spans
cameras
so here we have one truck visible and
five of the eight cameras and each image
has a very different perspective on the
truck so
to
weave these together to fuse it together
to say that this is really one truck
is a really challenging thing to
accomplish
okay so first
what i'm going to do
is show the benefit of operating the
vector space and then we'll start to
unpack it
same visual
curves and lines on the bottom left are
the is the fusion of these estimates in
the image space on the bottom right
is the fusion of these estimates in the
vector space and and this is clean this
is something
that can you can drive to
all right so
the transition to vector space has very
profound implications for how we think
about labels
data and the network architecture
i tend to think of data centric so we're
going to start with the data and the
labels we'll go through that end to end
and then we'll backtrack and come
through
the network architecture so labels
vector labels
okay airplane reference it's kind of
hard in zoom there's little feedback
but one of my favorite movies
all right so
this is going to be an important image
that we're going to see throughout the
presentation but we're still operating
in vector space these are going to be
features that drive the network and
ultimately
with this pixel here we want to detect
that it's a car
a view from image space a view of the
features
but let's rethink this in a vector space
so
ultimately
these features are going to land on a
pixel by pixel
raster
so let's imagine in this raster this
yellow box
and we know that's the curve
how does that project out into a vector
space so what we do
is we connect
that same
place that same location
across
multiple images
it's a projection
if we could do that it's great it's a
challenge because to do this with
precision
is not easy and that's a big reason why
the image space doesn't work
[Music]
but staying on the thread of labels
we're going to talk
about manual and auto labeling and we'll
touch on simulation at a later point
but they've really fundamentally
transformed how to label
first is manual
what we're looking at
here is a view of a human labeler uh and
this is the workstation the tool that
they're using to label it so let's
unpack this a little bit
um
this is in a small video clip that the
operator can move around the
orientations the perspectives and these
little blue lines that are changing
those are the labels for the curves
what makes it a vectorized
what makes it vectorized is as the
editing is occurring here in the video
it is simultaneously
occurring
in each of these images
one edit
across vector space
um
the benefit of this is is a massive
increase in in throughput using these
tools
um
but this does part of the bridge from
the image to the vector space
so
we often hear the term big data
that doesn't exactly describe the nature
of what needs to be solved here with the
autonomous driving and the reason is
to crack the code with autonomous
driving
um
there's a massive quantity of edge cases
so it really can be thought of both the
big data and a specific data problem
is uh here's an illustration
of what that might look like so
the context here is driving in the snow
the truck passes on the left throws up
some snow
and and the scene becomes obscured
okay
it's not and you can see as the snow
comes up in the image space
um the label
uh
the the detection of the objects in the
image uh degrades dramatically kind of
makes sense
fun fact
there are more than two million teslas
on the road
and inside each tesla there are two
high-speed computers
for vision processing one is driving the
car
the other serves a multiple purposes
it's testing the next version but it
also serves this purpose
and they can ask the fleet so they'll
take a video
of
a scenario an edge case where there's
grossly insufficient quantity of labels
and they'll say to the fleet
send back clips that look similar to
this
it's kind of cool
the result in this particular case
are these clips
so
in the span of a week 10 000 of these
clips were collected and labeled
and the impact to the estimation is here
so on the left
image space on the right
auto labeling
vector space
and it's kind of cool you see the snow
oh sorry about that you see the snow
thrown up
but the prediction persists across the
snow
i'm going to skip that
so these are some examples of how these
clips are used i'm going to brush over
this but
it enables tesla
to
massively increase the throughput of
what they can label
okay
so this is pretty cool here
what they've done these lines represent
curbs
and lines in the road
from the same location
across different trips
and
it's a different way of aggregating
labels but if you
aggregate these over time
it produces a
much crisper
much more effective labeling
of the surrounding
let's get that
okay so
vectors in this context exist both in
space and time
up until this point we've talked mostly
about space
um let's take a look at how vectors
play out across time
the problem presented
is
there are gaps in memory if we're
working in an image space so what's an
example you're stopped at a light
a car drives in front of you
as it drives in front of you it's going
to obscure what's behind it pedestrians
signs other cars there's a lack of
memory
so there's two things that
are presented to solve that the first
one i'll talk a little bit about a
spatial rnn the second comes in on the
planning side and the vision side we'll
talk about that in a little bit
um so what they use
again this is in the intuition we'll
talk about the architecture in a bit
it is a spatial rnn and the benefit of
the spatial rnn
a recurrent neural network
is it lays out the the rnn on an xy
coordinate
and by doing that
you can focus the predictions on the
immediate space around the car and what
that enables
is a better
estimation of the roads around you
the other benefit this drives
is
it enables predictions even when there
are temporary exclusions
occlusions pardon me um
so what we're seeing here
through these cameras and through this
visualization the blue blocks
are the estimates of
from the the vector space or the video
um the orange blocks are the estimates
from the single frame and what the blue
can do
that the image can't do is when the
truck drives in front we know that there
are two cars behind it
okay so we're getting closer to
unpacking the architecture
um
but before we get to the architecture
we're going to talk about planning and
planning so what's going on with
planning so this the place where we're
at now is we have
the vision networks have run they have
um
estimated the world around us in terms
of curbs lines other cars pedestrians
speed orientation road surface raining
snowing
so we have all these estimates what do
we do with it
we need to plan
and planning
is an optimization
problem
so
it's it's framed with
getting to the goal
while maximizing for safety comfort and
efficiency
so
a couple things about
optimization in this particular problem
um
the space is is non-convex
and you can easily get caught
in lots of local minimums
the other side of the problems of
software is it's a very high dimensional
analogy problem to solve for um
so
the approach
is to
carve off
sub
components of the space that we're going
to solve for
to create subsets
of the broader space that have convex
qualities so
think of it as a hybrid um
it's it's both core search to get
some arc that we're going to anchor to
and then within that arc or convex
corridor as it's referred to
we'll do
convex continuous optimization
so
here's an illustration of what that
looks like um
imagine we're this red car here and our
goal
is at the next intersection to make a
left
in between what we'll need to do
is
move over two lanes to the left
there's a couple of options we can take
given the other vehicles around us one
is we can slow down
and you can see that here the top graph
is position
uh the bottom graph is velocity so so
this particular plan says to slow down
not great doesn't give a great comfort
experience
another option is we can speed up
accelerate
but the risk here is if we accelerate
and don't make it around the next car in
time we'll miss the turn
ultimately what happens is
there are thousands of potential plans
out there and that's what's represented
in these graphs in terms of position in
terms of velocity
and that's where the optimization comes
in play in this particular instance
roughly 2500 potential plans
that
the searching and optimization for
occurs
in milliseconds
and ultimately
one path is selected
and then the car
that's the white path and the blue path
here
is the actual trajectory the car takes
so we're going to look at planning in a
different context and that's parking
so
the goal here
the the car is physically located here
and you want to park it here in green
and we're going to go through three
different approaches that have
dramatically different variants in the
space that they have to search
the first option
is going
to use the edges of this parking lot as
the bounding criteria for the search
space
ultimately uh the space here
is optimizing for euclidean distance
and given all these local
minimums we
the the car lands in uh is almost
400 000 different paths to get here
yes it gets there not so efficient
the second method
is this is where the convex corridor
gets introduced um
there are these arcs there's roughly
five of them
and the paths
are going to be anchored to that arc
so here
within the arc
we're looking at something that's much
more complex
still gets caught a little bit with some
of the cones
but eventually it's going to get there
in the neighborhood of 22 000
paths
pretty good
ultimately
um
the third method they approached
is a combination of monte carlo
states and actions and i don't know this
explicitly
but they alluded to the fact there's a
reinforcement learning quality to this
they
they connected this approach to things
like alphago
which is which is a deep reinforcement
learning problem
[Music]
but the idea is
to
to scan the environment to ascribe
rewards and states and actions and come
up with a heuristic that will
dramatically reduce the set of plans to
explore
and and this is the impact of that um
ultimately
it's dramatically smaller in orders of
magnitude um the quantity of plans that
are
the space the search base that is
explored
so
we've covered the intuition of vision
we've covered the planner both from an
intuition and a methodology
step um the next big thing to cover is
the architecture of the network
okay so hopefully
when we're finished with this uh we'll
have
a reasonable understanding of what's
going inside this network architecture
okay so the first step is raw images are
coming in
we want to
introduce those into the network
they're ultimately going to become
rasters
and the
the the architecture that tesla chose
here is a recurrent neural network for
this backbone
they chose regnets
the reason
for choosing regnuts is they have a very
nice trade-off between accuracy and
latency and what you can see here the
interesting part
as
as the features progress along this
backbone they'll start with a higher
resolution image with fewer channels
and they'll land the feature space
in a much lower resolution
with a higher channel count
why
the the view is that with the detailed
pictures
you can get
more effective
predictions within
a particular image
with the lesser
resolution and the greater channel count
there's a context for the images that's
very useful for the predictions
so
recurrent neural networks
regnet blocks
of variance in resolution and channel
count
so
we'd seen this image before
and and where this plays out
is
this pixels a car that's sort of the low
end the high resolution
but it's in the vanishing point of the
road which is
uh here with the less resolution the
context the higher channel counts and
that context makes it more effective
to estimate that this is in fact a car
the way to do that
is with the feature pyramid networks
the reason is
the these feature bi-directional feature
pyramid networks are very good at
sharing information
across these different streams up here
is the context up here
lower resolution down here
is more image focused with the higher
resolution
okay so
we have raw image we have recurrent
neural networks uh regnet blocks we have
bi-directional feature networks uh
pardon me future pyramid networks
all right we're assembling this slowly
next so what that's going to give us is
this raster of pixels
in deep learning these are the features
that the
network is going to learn or our
parameters so
what comes next
are detection we want to detect
something is it a car is it a
a bicycle a pedestrian etc
the approach they use here is yolo
yolo like is what they say
and the benefit of yolo is it can do the
prediction in a single pass versus
having to do multiple passes through the
image it's efficient
it's accurate at the end of this you're
going to get a
binary on
these pixels car no car things of that
nature
all right so now this is a cool pivot
point the reason it's a cool pivot point
is we're going to get into
multi-headed networks
it's a modular approach to deep learning
we don't want to just predict cars we
want to predict a lot of different
things
signs traffic lights curbs pedestrians
mailboxes um
each one of those
is
its own
prediction trunk
but you don't want to take the cost
of
creating these rasters and going through
the regnet and going through the future
pyramid network you want to take that
cost do it once and then apply apply it
across multiple
prediction heads
so
you get the benefit of execute ones used
many times
you can
cache the net the features here and disk
and train each and every one of these
individually
you can swap these in and out
um
and then periodically you can choose to
backprop and retrain the entire network
intent but you don't have to
so in short one image
many projections
but we're still in the image space
so
we still are working off of a single
label and we're still
not we haven't pulled together the
vector space yet
so how do we get there what does it look
like um
the thinking is we're going to have a
backbone
to create the rasters and features for
each and every one of the pictures
we're going to land them here in
something
that will enable us
to
to estimate
in vector space
so just
to refresh on this the vector space is
one one pixel one feature
connected to many images um one of the
big challenges in doing this
doing this well
is getting the position
right
across a lot of different perspectives
so
granular accuracies needed in space with
positions accurate positions
what kind of network architecture would
that suggest
transformers um
so
this is where
things
come together um this is where we start
um the transition into vector space so
at least from an architecture view
the really nice thing about transformers
is they have an encoding specific for
the position
and they
the network learns what the meaning and
value of that positional encoding is so
if we pivot just briefly into natural
language processing
where transformers are used
extensively
the position of a word in a sentence or
a paragraph has meaning
in that position
of each and every word is a feature
inside the deep learning network and
that's
a big part of the value of the
transformer architecture so
um essentially
what's happening here is we come up
through the transformer where's my mouse
sorry it's on the other screen there we
go
so all of this is the transformer um
we have the positional encoding here
there's the the context of what the
image is
um it comes through a multi-layer
perceptron and ultimately it's going to
come into two places a query and a key
value pair um and it's what the query is
saying
is hey
i'm a pixel
um
and i'm looking for stuff that's related
to me
in the key value pair
it's saying it's each image broadcasting
um hey i'm part of a curb
um and i'm seeing this kind of stuff
it's raining uh it's about to turn and
these two
the the key value pair and the query
they have a multiplicative effect that
um
brings them together
um and all of this gets
optimized by the deep learning network
so
looking back
all of that network architecture comes
to play
to bring all of these images together
and to do the estimations in the vector
space
[Music]
this is a visualization
of
a car driving in traffic and the thing
to look here the thing to call out is
the difference between the blue vector
space predictions and the orange image
space predictions
and you see how the orange has this
jittery quality what's happening is
as
cars
cross
image boundaries
it's very challenging for
for the network to place where that car
is and and whereas in the vector space
it's a far
smoother
estimation
so
we've gone through this
portion of the network i'll touch
briefly on these
um
so what's going to we we've detected all
the objects
what's going to happen is they're going
to get pushed onto a queue they can get
pushed onto the queue
either
through time increments through space
increments
um
that's what's going to feed all of the
the optimization
and that's what solves for the memory so
so that a car
has passed it in front of us
that these features
are on a queue
we retain it and we the the network can
know what's behind this car
there's a whole method in terms of when
to push on cue it's over time
uh it's over space
we spoke about that i'm going to skip
that but i did want to show
with the spatial rnns
what this visualization is showing
is
each across each channel the channel is
anchoring to a different estimation it's
some are anchoring to curbs some are
anchoring to the
the
center of the road others are anchoring
to the texture of the road
a different view of the spatial rnm
see
and that's the essence of it that's
that's the essence
of tesla's architecture
okay um
much of this is coding on part b is is
the architecture of the network um
but i did want to share this code
fragment because it's it's
i think captures part of the essence and
at least it brought it to life for me
um
in terms of how to optimize across all
these different heads on the network
and and the essence of it is
each head
has its own loss metric
whatever loss you want to anchor to uh
it could be cross entropy
mean square
it doesn't matter you choose um
and you calculate each loss individually
across your x's and your labels
uh your inputs your labels and then you
bring it all together you bring them all
together into one total loss with
weights that you can choose
against each law
so when you forward prop and back prop
across the network
what the deep learning network is going
to do is it's going to minimize this
total loss
there's lots of great sources online if
if you want to see how to code these but
i wanted to highlight this particular
portion of the method
because it's very relevant for some of
the opportunities
uh or
hypothesis would be a better way to say
it
that i and my team are exploring
um so what so so it's cool stuff in the
driving space how might that apply to
other industries um
it has to me the vector you know
the way it's presented by tesla
the the container for the vector is a
raster
but what if we think of that container
in different contexts
it could be a customer journey
it could be a shopping basket
it could be
a functional perspective if if you're at
a large corporation
and you want to
have a basket of cross-sell models
across a variety of products
one hypothesis
is to
make each product a different head on
the network they can share features you
can spin off features that are specific
to products
and
a potential benefit
is that you can take many models and
combine them into one
i don't think
it would work
where you'd want a bestoke mod a bespoke
model
where you'd want to eke out
every basis point of left because of the
economic impact but if you have a few
dozen models that are cross cells that
are fairly generic
the hypothesis is perhaps do that as one
deep learning multi-headed model
okay so it's kind of fun to talk about
flying cars jet packs
self-driving cars
but let's look at this through an
economic lens for a moment
according to the u.s census
in 2017
there are 3.5 million truck drivers in
the united states so
if we think about the potential impact
of these methods
to the economy to society
[Music]
it's potentially it's this massive game
changer that has
massive massive impacts potentially you
can debate well will it happen in five
years will it happen in 25 years
i don't claim to have the answer but
in my simple mind it's not a question of
if it's a question of one
all right so i know before we talked
about questions jared you wanted to
do some giveaways
before the giveaway
a round of applause
um
that was a really great talk a lot going
on in there it seems like it must take
you a long time to uh
develop this deep understanding of it so
i appreciate all the prep work you did
let's
say
it was fun it was a fun exercise good
i'm very glad i'm very glad you had uh
you had a good time good time learning i
had a good time watching you i'm glad
you had a good time learning it
uh before i do the giveaways if anyone
has questions i forgot to announce this
before the talk
post them
either in the chat here and zoom that's
the non-preferred way or in the meetup
channel
on the myhakkar meetup there is a
channel called monthly meetup chat go
post your questions there it's easier
for me to copy and paste uh to take
notes with but uh please if you have
questions
while i'm announcing the giveaways now's
a good time to think of those questions
or go ahead and ask them so i'll give
everyone a chance to ask the questions
as i do giveaways and we'll have some
we'll you know we'll grill bill a little
bit
so the first book
good code bad code by tom long
is going to thomas caisson
thomas congrats on getting a copy of
this book
to redeem your book
message nicole deljudis that's uh you'll
see her in the
zoom chat either message her on zoom
before we end please or on um meetup uh
she's at the anime hacker meetup her
username is just nikhil deljudis or
email her at um
yeah nicole landyanalytics.com there's a
three ways to get in touch with her
i'm out of voice so use one of those
three ways to get in touch with the zoom
chat her email or my hack r get your
book
uh the next book five lines of code by
christian
claussen
the winner for this is connie x
connie same thing email slack or zoom uh
nicole if you're gonna do it zoom do it
now before um we end it because
otherwise you won't be able to do it so
let's slack get more time and then the
third book street coder by sadat kappa
no blue the winner is dimitri melish
maleshko damichi maleshko
congratulations on your book same thing
go ahead and um
message goal and by the way just
everyone knows this was done randomly as
we always do all of our giveaways um
we literally um we didn't literally pick
uh names out of a hat because we don't
have a hat or printed names but it's
essentially the same process as that so
congratulations to our three winners and
remember everyone else who didn't get a
ball 35 off is a big discount and you
could do that with code mtp nystat22
any of manning's products you can go get
a discount on
so
with our three winners congratulations
let's get into some questions let me
just uh check this off and get to what
i've compiled
um
the tool question
um i think one of your slides sort of
gave a hint but what are they using for
the neural networks is it torch is it
keras is it something else
uh they never specifically get into that
there are hints around pie torch um
the gentleman andre parte who's the
director of vision um
uh he created the stanford convolutional
neural network class and posted that
online that's all on torch so
um
i'm pretty certain it's torch but i
cannot say that with certainty
and you did mention yolo i know the yolo
v5 is torch-based but there's like four
other yolos um but you said it's yellow
like so that might give a hint too i
guess right if that is torch-based maybe
that works in there
that's right that's right and there's a
lot of
um
other folks that i follow on twitter
um that tend to
have a take towards torch so
if i had to bet i would say torch but i
wouldn't pound the table here with
certainty
that's fair
um and again
you might not know this this question
but like any clue they've hinted at how
long these models take to train and like
how many machines and gpus they're using
to train them
there's actually a very cool story
beyond that so the whole ai day
spanned three hours uh the vision and
the planning that we went through was
approximately an hour and a half
beyond that
they
they announced that
they have a full stack development their
vertically integrated company so they
want to make all portions of the tesla
they're bringing that perspective to ai
what does that mean that means they have
their own chip they have their own
version of a gpu they have their own
cluster they're building out a massive
massive farm
of
hardware that is specifically designed
and tuned for ai
um
so they have a massive amount of
of hardware behind this
um
it's actually very cool
i can throw the link on the
the presentation um
but they're doing they're investing a
ton
into a fully vertical vertically
integrated ai solution and
i'm purely speculating here
it wouldn't surprise me if they brought
that to market as their own product but
that's purely me guessing
when you say the product you mean like
the ai solution of the actual hardware
itself
the hardware
so you did allude to that they have open
source some stuff so be cool to open
source some of their software that'd be
really awesome maybe more of it i
suppose
that'd be very cool that would be very
cool the the other cool spin on it was
just before they announced that they're
building um
they're bringing to market a robot
product
um
and it was just in the headlines this
week because they're they're saying it
will be on the market in 2023
um
they portray themselves not as an
automobile manufacturer rather they see
these as
robots with wheels
given given the amount of intelligence
that's baked into it i thought that was
kind of a cool way to position it that
was cool
uh one logistical question let me get
back to content questions there is a
question will this be recorded will be
shared yeah the videos will go up to
our youtube channel within a day or two
along with slideshows and you get all
the information at myhackguard.org our
brand new website saying when looking
for the recordings or the slides go
there
um so back to content questions uh in
switching to vector space how important
are synthetic data sets
that's a great question um
there's a whole thread here
uh which wasn't touched on at all
um
there are three ways tesla's approaching
labels one is the
the manual label labeler that we saw
with the video clip the other is pull
the fleet
the third is simulation
[Music]
i didn't have time to get that in here i
didn't know if it would resonate with
this audience
they're doing a massive amount with
simulation
with simulation in this context meaning
we dream up
an edge case a goofy one of people
running down the highway
and they do it they simulate it in a
very realistic way
with the texture
the the
light
shading
and by simulating it
you now have
new data that is fully labeled
so that's a big part of their strategy
for
managing the edge cases
so i'm putting
i'm projecting into synthetic of the
simulation and i think i think that's on
uh solid enough ground because those are
not real labels they're completely
human computer generated
and they portray that
as the interface and interface um
between human and computer
yes and i imagine by simulations they
also do like like you showed how they
play out scenarios if you turn left what
happens you turn left at a different
angle what happens and what if that gets
fed back into the loop too somewhere
totally totally or if there's a new car
that's going to hit the road that's not
in production yet
get ahead of it put it into your
simulation label it and throw it into
the next training room
and do you know if these simulations are
these weird scenarios like they occur
for the lighting like on a rainy day a
cloudy day a sunny day does that get
into very much
like if you look at them
the detail in there is remarkable
because
usually the tell
is in the
the perspective of the shadow
and it looks frighteningly accurate
um
now there's another question they
probably have thousands of features
collected by camera
do you have any sense of how these
inputs are selected by tesla engineers
how they properly do future selection
and and engineer the features that
anything come across about that
so
i think the question is how to feature
engineer the data that comes through
cameras
versus what's simulated yeah
sure
um because i'm not sure about the
context of this question um basically
yeah how do they if they have thousands
of features i guess what is a feature i
guess it's the pixels so maybe there's
not a lot of yeah how do they decide
like should we look at shadows of
objects or should we look at you know
implied heights of objects maybe that's
the question
so so
one of the cool things about the deep
learning is is that those rasters that
pixel that says car not car it has
um
it has
an array
um up against a torch array it's like a
lot like a numpy array um and each bit
has um essentially a deep learning
equivalent of a coefficient
and in the backward propagation
is saying well if it's this value
what is the total loss
do some gradient descent that gives you
the direction to change it
um change it
change that that that single pixel
coefficient or feature i'll use
coefficient and feature interchangeably
for the moment come up with a better
coefficient
and that's the essence of the back
propagation so so think of each feature
as a deep learning equivalent of the
coefficient
okay
and yes if the coefficient is close to
zero the future doesn't matter
that's right exactly that's that's
exactly it jared is that the
the deep learning is describing
the value
and that we're not necessarily in this
context
there's nothing said we didn't talk
about it all tonight any kind of feature
engineering
the the thinking
is in how to architect the network the
thinking is how to present the data into
the network
i wonder how yeah i wonder if they have
more insight if they give more insight
into how they do present it to the
network but you know there's only so
much they give out all right
that's right but one of the hard parts
is to train these multi-headed networks
they're very very challenging to train
but if you get it right there's a lot of
benefit
um speaking of complications what do
they do they have anything they talk to
anything about like dirty or smudged
cameras
huh
that is a great question
so it turns out um
as the tesla fleet evolved over time
there are
nuanced differences in the cameras
um
which becomes very important
to
how i don't know let's let's make up an
example jared has a new tesla and i have
an old one right
we might have different
um
what's the word i'm looking for uh
distortion slight distortions in the two
cameras
and that was a big thing they spoke to
is that they had to
almost bake features into the network
to account for that because if you don't
the new tesla that you have the old one
i have in this made-up scenario um would
present very different to the network so
they have to normalize that
or even where over time your camera
started out as a different camera then
you've been driving it for seven years
these cars are going 80 miles per hour
hitting bumps you know things get
damaged
that's right that's right that's a great
point
and do they
do they mention it all if they're using
like lidar or radar in addition to
visual
so they made wavelengths
very conscious
design decision
to eliminate radar
their view is
humans drive based purely on vision and
sound and that radar is an unnecessary
complication
so they have very
publicly and visibly
pushed to eliminate radar
out of their
their um their models the cars many of
the cars have radar but they're they're
pushing to
train only by vision
or no i should say they're training to
use
no radar eliminate radar i do believe
they've hinted at that they might use
sound too so
and i guess lidar counts as radar so
that's you know they're eliminating that
as well
the interesting about sound now when you
say sound is it like sonar they're
sending pings or is it just you know
they're capturing sound like things
things record i've only gotten hints at
this so for in preparing for this they
actually went through the owner's manual
and they talk about microphones in the
car um
what its use is
i can conjecture but wouldn't know
okay
all right that makes sense as humans
what they see now that's actually
another question
what wavelengths of light are those
cameras capturing is that ultraviolet to
infrared or is it just literally visual
spectrum
that's a good question i i don't have an
equally good answer
i do know that they
they've standardized by 1280 but i think
it's 960 frames 35 hertz
um in that some of the cameras are
fisheyed
so you get a broader field of view
um
hey you got me curious now it's a good
question uh i haven't heard anything
that talks to a visible frequency but
they could in theory
um expand beyond what we can see
because you think about like and i know
satellites use different wavelengths to
get through clouds and fog is just a
cloud on the earth right so maybe it
needs to get through the fog
totally totally and and
it wouldn't the economics of it would be
minimal yeah just another
you know just another channel
okay
cool
um and you talked about the losses
being computed all together so i guess a
few parts that one how do they decide
the waiting for each head
right and
because you said you know you have like
the different types of loss you multiply
it by its weight to come up with total
loss so a how do they come up with the
weighting how much each head is worth is
that itself optimized or is that humans
you know choosing it then also why not
just compute the loss for each head
separately and then combine them
so i'll speak generically because i
haven't heard um anything publicly said
about that
but they do train
each
part of me each um
head
individually it's a great way to split
work across teams right you're
you're the team that's
dealing with stop signs traffic lights
pedestrians so it compartmentalizes the
problem very very nicely and they do
cache
to disk
features
along the way so if you have an intense
focus on a particular head of the
network you can do that
so there's lots of design cycle design
sprints
that are focused on particular heads but
ultimately you have to bring it all
together i haven't heard anyone publicly
talk about how they weight it what i've
done in my shop is we
we come up with a weighting in theory
you could bake that into the network to
weight that but there's a lot of design
considerations if
if you have um
unbalanced data that might
um that would be a big factor in how the
model might react to that
okay
great
um that's all the questions i had so far
if there's any last-minute questions
now's the time to do it i'll get rid of
one like you 20 seconds uh or however
long it takes me to make closing
announcements i'll starts very slowly
and i'm buying time right now closed
yard i know if anyone was uh
you and i were talking about sometime
the way we initially conceived of this
as doing it as the brooklyn bridge yeah
i was wondering what happened to the
brooklyn bridge i didn't want to say
anything
no no it's good i have it i i struggle
i've got the whole presentation
and i think it's a really cool story
it's like
it's
it's such a great metaphor like on so
many levels like it's bridging
geographies like what we do is at least
what i do as a data scientist you bridge
the statistics and the business the
technology and the data
it was designed by an immigrant it was
built by his immigrant son and
there's so many good stories it was the
first use of
of um
steel
in building and it showed the city how
to build fur i can go on for a long time
it's a great story i struggled
with the transition
from what tesla is doing here to what
the brooklyn bridge is doing innovation
so it's it's a story for another day if
you're came from now they're going to
schedule you for another talk i mean
that's just what it's going to come down
to now
perfect yeah
um well you're telling us about the
brooklyn bridge and i do want to see
this talk i think that will be awesome
we are you know but even though we now
are like a global meetup we're still in
new york meetup and we would like to see
what the bridge had actually made in new
york city into one city before that the
five boroughs were a separate city well
not all five of them there was probably
two or three separate cities but you
know they combined
different before the bridge and after
they merged together yeah
yep so i would love to see that talk and
while you were talking about that
there's a question if you know if the
chips tesla is customizing are they arm
based or some other architecture
custom they're a vertically integrated
company
they pride themselves
on the full vertical stack
so much so
what i've heard from people that have
worked there way back when they used to
build their own erp software but
it's their own custom chip it is
designed
for massive i o
because of all the dot products that are
going on so it is a chip from scratch
that was
designed to do
deep learning
fast so it's more than like an asic even
than a cpu or gpu
yeah it's very very very fast and then
they put a bunch of them together on a
board so they have their own
version of the gpu
it's um
if you put a bunch of smart people
together and said
make the best hardware you can
for
ai and deep learning
is what they aspire to be
now i'm curious who's manufacturing is
it tsmc or do they even have their own
chip fab like or these global foundries
or
that's a good question that's a really
good question you know they're big on
manufacturing um
i wonder
because chip manufacturing is actually
built around their business almost not a
one player but it's a very small field
or at least maybe out of the gate they
outsource it and then eventually bring
it in house yeah
that'd be very interesting
good question and you say the other day
i i saw a little roadster turned out to
be a tesla roadster
and i never heard of this i'm trying to
that's what they originally were making
little roadsters before elon musk got
there i think
interesting
look it up it's pretty it was a pretty
busy looking car i was so very shocked
by it and nothing to do with earlier
presentation but it's very i saw that in
like that's a tesla i never heard of it
and i looked up before elon got there i
think they were making these little like
little like a two-person roadster it's
very cool
very cool i heard a fun edge case um as
some of my colleagues were helping me uh
with the articulations apparently the
full self-driving does not work in
toronto it's turned off
a legal thing
the old trolley system
is on the wrong side of the road
so people exit out of sides that are not
expected
um
they turned it off they turned tesla
turned off the full self-driving in
downtown toronto
i imagined to do similar things for
driving in london or in hong kong or
singapore anywhere they drive on the
left
there's a great part of the video i was
attempted to put in
um
where they showed this crazy chaotic
traffic circle in india
and and there's just a different
rules of the road for walking and it's
it's it's show no fear and people and
and
um motorcycles and scooters coming out
of every direction and the haunting is
important there actually honking is very
important going yes yeah
yes and that's a big part of the
thinking behind some of the planning
that we saw so that
um monte carlo what i suspect is
reinforcement learning
is
in part intended to overlay the value
system onto those
traffic systems and make it a more
generalized solution across different
traffic contexts
that is really awesome
and i think we have exhausted all the
possible questions
so i want to give a big thank you to
bill i'll give my golf clap here
hopefully we'll give a virtual golf club
in the chat
i had a fantastic time learning um it's
always fun when bill gives a talk yeah i
can't wait to see you in person again
hopefully soon if someone gives us
office space maybe [ __ ] has office space
or anybody else can give us some space
uh we'll do it again in person
so that everyone check your company has
like a cafeteria area with a projector
they want to host us in check your
company come to the conference june 8th
through 10th and use discount code ny
hack r to get a 20 discount uh check out
demanding books get your discounted
books you know get them on a discount
the next few meetups uh we have some
speakers lined up we're trying to see if
they're going to be in person so we're
not announcing anything yet but april
may june we'll have you know we'll have
speakers every month
and um so make sure i'm not let me make
sure i'm not forgetting anything give me
one second here oh if you're looking to
hire go to the job postings channel of
the meetup
and visit our new website nyhakar.org
same address brand new website far
better than it used to be so everyone
enjoy that and remember there's 12 years
worth of slide shows 13 years worth of
slideshows and videos probably seven
years worth of videos uh there's so much
and also the our staff that ai
seven years of videos up there too so
lots and lots of content to learn um
lots of good stuff out there everyone
have a great night and thank you very
much again to bill this is really
excellent and we're gonna have you again
back to the uh brooklyn bridge thank you
bill
awesome thanks be good everyone have a
good night
bye